The beloved actress who gave away the entire
plot of her movie on national television?
The actor from a massive film franchise spoiling
their character's death?
And, which actor got fired for his mistake?
Keep watching to be shocked about these spoilers!
David Prowse played Darth Vader in the original
Star Wars trilogy.
Or at least, he was the guy in the Vader costume
and helmet.
James Earl Jones provided the voice, and Sebastian
Shaw played the unmasked villain at the end
of Return of the Jedi.
Prowse's image wasn't as well-known as those
of co-stars like Mark Hamill or Harrison Ford.
But, the first wave of Star Wars mania in
1978 was so huge that a Prowse meet-and-greet
in Berkeley, California, drew 1,000 people.
The British actor delighted the audience at
the event with stories about his career and
the first Star Wars movie, including news
that a sequel was in pre-production.
Prowse promised that Star Wars II would feature
a lightsaber battle between Luke Skywalker
and Darth Vader.
And then he said that Darth Vader would reveal
to Luke that he was his father.
Star Wars II became The Empire Strikes Back,
of course, and it featured the exact same
twist Prowse had spoiled years before.
"That's impossible!"
Prowse wasn't the only cast member from The
Empire Strikes Back to spoil the movie.
Billy Dee Williams, who played the irresistibly
roguish Lando Calrissian, spilled another
Star Wars secret, but on a much higher-profile
venue: NBC's long-running morning show Today.
To be fair, Williams had to reveal that Lando
wasn't really a bad guy, just a crafty manipulator.
He seemed to get a little defensive when the
interviewer labeled his character as evil,
and decided to interject.
"He's not evil.
He's just a guy caught in a situation."
In the grand scheme of Star Wars spoilers,
it's a pretty minor reveal — but on the
other hand, it did ruin a pretty significant
plot twist for anyone who watched the interview
before the movie.
Like most time travel movies, The Time Traveler's
Wife has a complicated premise.
That makes for a fine line, then, between
explaining a movie's plot and spoiling the
movie entirely.
The Time Traveler's Wife star Rachel McAdams
accidentally crossed that line while promoting
the film on the Daily Show.
Host Jon Stewart asked how far outside the
present the story's time-traveling husband
was able to journey, and McAdams explained,
"He goes as far as his own childhood ... He
goes forward as far as his own death."
After a moment of silence in which McAdams
realized what she'd done, Stewart replied,
"Whoa!
He knows how he's gonna die before he dies?"
McAdams, a little embarrassed, sighed,
"Now we've ruined everything."
It's probably worth mentioning that the movie
was based on the 2003 bestseller of the same
name, and fans of the book most definitely
were already aware of the title character's
fate.
Still, promoting a film romance by spoiling
a death is usually not the best way to go.
Sylvester Stallone produced — and earned
a Best Supporting Actor nomination — for
his role in Creed, a Rocky franchise spinoff
that helped revive the blockbuster series
he created in the '70s.
In 2014, he tweeted out an artsy, sentimental
photo of the filmmaking process behind the
film with the caption: "Where the screenwriting
is done."
The picture showed a pair of glasses, some
handwritten notes...and the last page of the
script for Creed.
The page was upside down, but if fans wanted
to know how the movie ended, all they had
to do was flip the photo and zoom in a little.
Game of Thrones fans were thrilled when it
was announced that Ian McShane from Deadwood
would join the cast of HBO's epic fantasy
series in its sixth season.
In an interview on BBC Breakfast about his
role as Brother Ray, however, he gave away
a little too much.
McShane said,
"I bring back a much-loved character who everybody
thinks is dead."
Vanity Fair connected the dots and determined
that McShane meant the Hound, as actor Rory
McCann had been spotted on set.
Informed he'd upset some people with his casual
plot spoiling, McShane offered Game of Thrones
fans a verbal eyeroll.
He told the Telegraph,
"You say the slightest thing and the internet
goes ape.
I was accused of giving the plot away, but
I just think get a f--- life."
Logan marked the end of Hugh Jackman's 17-year
journey playing Wolverine across eight X-Men
films.
And while the X-franchise will continue with
the heroes played by younger actors, Wolverine
doesn't really age, so there was essentially
only one way that the character — and Jackman's
portrayal of him — could end: with Wolverine's
death.
Still, it wasn't cool when Jackman, on the
week Logan hit theaters, told Entertainment
Weekly that's how it ended.
He revealed,
"In the end, he must give his life to save
someone else ... I thought that was really
powerful."
He wasn't wrong, although it might have been
even more powerful if he'd managed to keep
it to himself.
Millions of people were excited for Rogue
One, the first in a planned series of standalone
Star Wars spinoff movies.
Among the most pumped?
The people who took time out of their lives
to attend Star Wars Celebration Europe, where
actor Jiang Wen blew the Rogue One ending
for everyone watching the conference.
Wen portrayed Baze Malbus, one of the members
of the ragtag group who comes together to
steal the plans for the Death Star to stop
the Empire.
Baze heroically dies in his mission, which
Wen mentioned during a livestreamed Star Wars
Celebration panel.
He would've revealed more details had panel
host Gwendolyn Christie not cut him off, warning,
"I think you've got to leave it there."
By the time Avengers: Infinity War hit theaters
in 2018, Mark Ruffalo had played the famously
green-skinned muscle man the Hulk in five
Marvel Cinematic Universe movies.
But somehow, he wound up leaking significant
details of two of those highly anticipated
films before they were released for the public.
Infinity War is the first in a two-film Avengers
finale and features a brutal and sad twist
ending in which intergalactic villain Thanos
snaps half of all life out of existence, including
many of the Avengers.
It's unbelievable, and it's even more unbelievable
that Ruffalo told the world such events would
happen during an appearance on Good Morning
America nearly a year before Infinity War
would arrive at cineplexes.
Ruffalo teased,
"Wait til you see this next one.
Everybody dies."
"Dude!
Dude!"
"Not everybody.
No."
Not long after the Good Morning America incident,
Ruffalo attended the premiere of the 2017
MCU entry Thor: Ragnarok in which he co-stars
as the Hulk.
At the premiere, he accidentally shared the
movie with anyone watching his Instagram live
feed.
By forgetting to switch off Insta before putting
his phone in his pocket, Ruffalo accidentally
streamed the first 20 minutes of the movie's
audio over the internet.
Tom Holland is a versatile actor and international
celebrity who does two things more than anything
else in his busy career.
He plays Spider-Man whenever the MCU requires
him to do so, and he routinely spoils sensitive
or top-secret details about those same MCU
films.
In June 2018, Holland put in an appearance
at ACE Seattle Comic Con and posted a video
to his Instagram page to calm down fans eager
for details about his upcoming second Spider-Man
film.
Tom said these words before ironically and
accidentally revealing the movie's name:
"I wanted to apologize because there's no
real revelations coming out this weekend about
'Spider-Man 2,' [...] I got the new script.
I'm super excited to read it.
It's gonna be great!"
The funniest part is that Holland said all
this while holding up the iPad upon which
he was reading the script, with the not-yet-public
title, Spider-Man: Far From Home very visible.
Here's a spoiler alert for Avengers: Infinity
War — Spider-Man dies in the end.
A crowd filled a theater at the ArcLight in
Los Angeles for a special early screening
of that film hosted by directors Joe and Anthony
Russo, along with some of the cast members.
Holland came out on stage and quipped, "I'm
alive!"
Though obviously confused about whether he
was walking out before or after the screening,
Holland coyly but clearly revealed his character's
fate.
"That was a test right?
There's, uh, nobody back there?"
"Yes, you've passed."
Plenty of superhero movies are also origin
stories that lay the groundwork for future
sequels by showing how a regular individual
acquires their superpowers and embraces their
extraordinary lot in life.
Aquaman, the 2018 mega-blockbuster entry in
DC Comics' cinematic universe, features Jason
Momoa as the title lord of the seas, reprising
the role he plays in 2017's team-up movie
Justice League.
At the time, filmgoers might not all have
anticipated Aquaman to be an origin story
that takes place before the events of Justice
League.
But they soon found out as much, thanks to
an excitable Momoa sharing a little too much
about the movie — particularly its ending
and his character's arc — during his promotional
rounds for Justice League.
As he told SFX Magazine,
"He's not even really Aquaman yet.
He's not the King of the Seven Seas.
We don't really get there until my solo movie,
at the end.
Really, it's a huge growth for me.
It's a gigantic arc for Arthur Curry."
Guardians of the Galaxy was something of a
surprise hit in 2014, because it's based on
more obscure source material than previously
successful MCU outings like Iron Man, Captain
America, and Thor.
Only relatively hardcore comics fans knew
what to expect from Guardians.
Hardly anybody could predict how events would
unfold in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2,
which hit theaters in 2017.
The sequel adds mysterious new characters
to the mix, including Ayesha, played by Australian
actor Elizabeth Debicki.
While discussing and promoting the movie at
San Diego Comic-Con in the summer of 2016
which was a year before the film would see
release, Debicki laid out most of Ayesha's
arc.
Unfortunately she also included one of the
film's twists — she isn't one of the good
guys.
In fact, Ayesha is a villain who tricks the
protagonists into fighting on her behalf.
As she told Gizmodo at San Diego Comic Con,
"Ayesha is this leader of the Sovereign people.
She enlists the Guardians to help her fight
a sort of galactic beast.
It's all going swimmingly until it all turns
very very sour.
Let's just say it goes from amiable to not-so-amiable
quite quickly."
Actor Rodri Martin works primarily in Spanish-language
media.
In 2021, he landed a very plum gig — performing
the dub for actor Evan Peters in the Spanish
version of the Disney+ MCU series WandaVision.
Peters' appearance on the show as Pietro Maximoff,
who was presumed dead, is a mega-surprise
in the complicated, slow-boil world of WandaVision.
According to Cinexcepcion, Martin revealed
his casting on Twitter ahead of Pietro's big
Episode 5 reveal, which violated Martin's
confidentiality agreement with Disney and
Marvel.
Martin also told Twitter that he'd be dubbing
Peters' lines in future MCU projects — which
means, ironically, at that point Martin either
didn't really know how WandaVision ends or
was trying to throw fans off the track of
figuring out the real deal with Pietro.
The source states that for potentially spoiling
multiple projects and ignoring contract language,
Disney terminated Martin and replaced him
with Manuel Gimeno, the actor who performed
the dubs for Charlie Cox in Marvel's Daredevil
series.
While the Star Wars prequels weren't as well-received
as the original trilogy, there are some undeniably
great elements of the films — such as the
always terrific Samuel L. Jackson as a Jedi
named Mace Windu.
Prior to the release of the final prequel,
Revenge of the Sith, Jackson sat for an interview
with Now Playing.
When asked what Windu would be doing in the
film, Jackson answered, "Dying!"
He then added that he couldn't go into too
much detail, but that his character would
face "an awesome death."
Of course, hardcore Star Wars fans were already
aware that the Jedi faced near-total extinction
during the events leading up to the original
trilogy, so Windu's death wasn't totally a
surprise.
Still, having it confirmed this way counts
as something of a disturbance in the Force.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
talkative actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.